عما زال هناك هدوء حذر في العاصمه الخرطوم
بمدنها ثلاث لكنه في منطقه شرق الخرطوم
هذه المنطقه التي نحن الان متواجدين فيها
الهدوء هنا يعني تشوبه كذلك حركه حركه
للمواطنين بالنسبه للمواطنين الذين يودون
الخروج من ولايه الخرطوم يضاف اليهم بعض
المواطنين الذين يريدون قضاء بعض
احتياجاتهم استغلالا لهذا الهدوء الذي
يعتبر مسيطر لوقت طويل منذ البارحه حتى
حتى اليوم عدا قليل من الاشتباكات في
مناطق متفرقه وبعيده من هذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه تشهد هدوء حذرا او نسبيا مع حركه
للمواطنين كذلك بحثا عن احتياجاتهم وكذلك
للوصول الى واحده من المحطات التي يغادرون
منها الى الولايات الشرقيه والولايات
الجنوبيه كذلك
طيب خروج هؤلاء المواطنين من مناطق
الخرطوم كما تفضل سالم يعني هل يبدو ميسرا
لان هناك العديد من الارتكازات للطرفين
قوه الدعم السريع بحسب بعض الانباء في
مناطق عده في ولايه السودان
صحيح احمد هذا مؤكد لكن في بعض الطرق الان
تكون سالكه خاصه في الصباح دائما نشهد ان
هذه الطرقات حتى وان كانت فيها القوات في
الصباح تكون هنالك حركه شبه طبيعيه تستمر
حتى الثانيه عشره والواحده ظهرا ثم بعد
ذلك تبدا يا موضوع تقل هذه الطرقات الى ان
تصل ذروتها في بمغيب الشمس سيصبح المرور
من هذه الطرقات الصعبه للغايه ربما
المواطنين الان يعني يجتهدون في قضاء
احتياجاتهم من الخروج لقضاء بعض ما
يحتاجونه من اكل وشرب وكذلك ما يحتاجونه
ايضا في بقيه مستلزماتهم الاخرى ايضا
لاحظنا ايضا عدد من المواطنين يخرجون بحثا
عن الوقود الذي فيه ندره حقيقيه في هذه
المنطقه وفي الاطراف كذلك موجود لكنه
بصعوبه هنا شبه منعدم هذا العنصر وهو
الوقود الذي يحتاجونه للحركه كذلك
المواصلات لم تعمل بشكل كامل هناك الان
قليل من العربات والسيارات التي يعني
يقتنيها المواطنون كمواصلات لكنها محدوده
جدا في طرق معينه جدا في محطات معينه كذلك
الوضع الامني ايضا في خرطوم كيف يمكن وصفه
سالم بالحديث عن عمليات سلب ونهب ربما
نفذت في بعض المناطق في الايام الماضيه
[موسيقى]
نعم احمد رصدت العديد من
الملفات المتعلقه بالسلب والنهب والشكاوى
والمواطنين المتكرره من هذا الامر في
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم هذا
الملف الامني حقيقه من الملفات المؤرقه
للمواطن السوداني في ظل هذه الظروف
ظروف صعبه حقيقه
بان يعني خاصه بعد مغيب الشمس ربما تنشط
هذه الحركات الاجراميه بالنهب والسلب
للمواطنين بالوصول الى منازلهم كذلك اخذ
ما يملكونه ثم بعد كل حادثه نجد
تبادل الطرفين للاتهامات ولكن في هنا
حقيقه مهمه ايضا احيانا تكون هذه العمليات
او غالبا تكون ليست من الطرفين اصلا
وهنالك ربما العمليات الاجراميه ربما هذه
المرحله وهذا الوقت مرتع خصب لمثل هذه
العمليات في ظل غياب الشرطه غياب دورها في
حمايه الممتلكات والمواطنين ربما هذا يدفع
ضعاف النفوس الى الذهاب لاخذ اموال الناس
والنهب والسلب كذلك فهذه من الملفات
المؤرقه تضاف الى فاتوره هذه الحرب خدمات
الكهرباء والمياه والانترنت ايضا هل عادت
ولو بشكل جزئي كيف هو وضعها حاليا في
الخرطوم
نعم احمد بالنسبه
للكهرباء هي ربما تكون الافضل في الثلاثه
الذين ذكرت الكهرباء هناك شاعله لوصولها
لكل المواطنين لكن ما زالت هناك مناطق
فيها تذبذب في التيار الكهربائي ومناطق
اخرى لا يوجد فيها تيار كهربائيه اصلا منذ
اندلاع هذه الازمه لكن ربما هناك مجهودات
تقدم من الشركه القوميه للكهرباء بحثا عن
حلول
لمشكله الكهرباء ووضع حلول لها في ظرف
حقيقه امني صعب جدا في ظل انتشار للقوات
عدم التزام بالهدنه بشكل كامل كل هذه
الامور تجعل عمال الكهرباء يجدون صعوبه في
الوصول اما بالنسبه للاتصالات ففيها تذبذب
واضح ايضا حتى هذه اللحظه هناك اشكال واضح
في الاتصالات بكل اشكالها سواء الانترنت
او حتى الاتصالات اما بالنسبه للمياه فما
زالت مدينه بحره هي الاكثر ضررا بموضوع
المياه يضاف اليها بعض الاح ياء في
الخرطوم وام درمان بكل تاكيد لكن المدينه
تبحري تعاني حقيقه من انقطاع مياه منذ اول
يوم لاندلاع هذه الازمه حتى هذه اللحظه 15
يوما حقيقه كانت عصيبه او ما زالت عصيبه
كذلك دفع الكثير من المواطنين بالخروج من
مدينه بحري او كذلك الاعتماد على المياه
الجوفيه وهي مياه غير صالحه للشرب لمتابعه
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات